[Music]
what do we know about the practice of
beekeeping do you know this is a
business in itself beekeeping farms are
very common now the earliest humans
would have procured honey directly from
the natural beehives well this is far
from safe imagine a swarm of bees
stinging all at once if there's even a
slight error on a part beekeeping
nowadays is done in a structured manner
small wooden craters are specially
designed to create an artificial home
for the bees this is an extremely low
investment business and is surely
profitable it serves as an additional
income to all farmers do you know that
these beehives can also be a source of
wax yes they are local varieties of bees
are usually used to produce honey for
commercial gain do you want to learn the
scientific names of a few local
varieties of bees what do you think the
indian v is called it is known as the
apis cerana indica while the rock bee is
known as the apis dorset are the little
bee and the italian b are known as the
apis flore and the apis mellifera
respectively the Italian variety is
commonly used for commercial honey
production well that's a lot to learn
but tell me one thing what is the
difference between the Italian variety
of bees and the local varieties the
Italian variety possesses some good
characteristics firstly they produce
more honey than the usual ones secondly
they sting less and lastly they stay in
one be high for a considerably long time
these are enough reasons to prefer them
over the local varieties do you know a
bee farm has a special name yes
it's called an apiary the name comes
from the genus name of the bees apis as
you must have just observed in their
scientific names what factors do you
think bee farms depend on for the
quality of the honey
firstly quality depends on the flowers
that are available to the bees flowers
are the source of nectar better the
quality of flowers
better the quality of honey would you
like to know a few amazing facts about
bees a bee has to travel to around 50 to
100 flowers during one collection trip
it is believed that a worker bee visits
about two million flowers to make just
one pound of honey well now you know how
many bees would have worked in order to
provide us with one jar of honey how
much honey do you think an average
worker bee makes in its lifetime it
would surprise you to know that one
average worker bee makes just 1/12 of a
teaspoon all its life and bees work
non-stop during the day to garner nectar
that's how the expression as busy as a
bee came into existence bees have been
producing honey for the past 10 to 20
million years thanks to them we are
privileged to be consumers of this
amazing product called honey next time
you pass by an apiary do drop in and
witness this amazing process be sure not
to touch or disturb the bees though
[Music]